Professor Christine
Hayes: We were talking last
time about evidence of the use
of different sources in the
biblical text,
and I mentioned Richard Simon,
who was the first to argue that
perhaps Moses wasn't the author
of the entire Torah.
In the mid-eighteenth century a
fellow named Jean Astruc first
noticed the use of the name
Yahweh in certain stories and
passages,
and the name Elohim in others.
And on this basis he came,
and others came,
to identify what have come to
be known as the J and E sources.
J being pronounced "y" in
German, as a "Y," so Yahweh is
spelt with a "J".
So the J and the E sources.
Now Astruc actually happened to
maintain the idea of Mosaic
authorship.
He argued the Moses was drawing
from two separate long
documents, which he identified
as J and E.
They used different names for
God, and he was drawing on those
in his composition of the Torah.
But in the next century his
work would be expanded by
Germans who identified other
sources that made up the
Pentateuch especially,
the first five books of the
Bible especially.
And in 1878 we have the classic
statement of biblical source
theory published by Julius
Wellhausen.
He wrote a work called The
History of Israel,
and he presented what is known
as the Documentary Hypothesis.
Now you've read a little bit
about this in your source
readings, but it's the
hypothesis that the historical
or narrative sections of the
Bible--Genesis and stretching on
really through 2 Kings--is
comprised of four identifiable
source documents that have been
woven together in some way.
And he argued that these
documents date to different
periods and reflect very
different interests and
concerns.
These four prior documents,
he says, were woven together by
somebody or some group of
somebodies to form the narrative
core of the Bible.
Wellhausen argued that these
sources therefore do not tell us
about the times or situations
they purport to describe,
so much as they tell us about
the beliefs and practices of
Israelites in the period in
which they were composed.
This is going to be an
important claim;
this is an important predicate
of the documentary hypothesis.
So although the sources claim
to talk about events from
creation, actually,
forward,
Wellhausen says,
no, they really can only be
used to tell us about the
beliefs and religion of Israel
from the tenth century,
which is when he thinks the
oldest was written,
and forward.
Now his work created a
sensation.
It undermined of course
traditional claims about the
authorship of God and the work
of Moses.
It's still disputed by
conservative groups and Roman
Catholic authorities,
although Roman Catholic
scholars certainly teach it and
adopt it.
The four sources that were
identified by Wellhausen are,
as I said, the J source and the
E source,
but also P, the priestly
source, and D,
which is primarily the book of
Deuteronomy.
Now as I said the first two
sources are named because of the
names of God that they employ,
but it goes a little deeper
then that.
According to J,
the knowledge of the proper or
personal name,
if you will,
of God, Yahweh,
begins with the first human,
with the adam.
So already in Genesis 4,
adam seems to know this
name and refer to God by this
name.
If we look at other sources
such as P and even E,
Yahweh's name is not known to
humankind until he chooses to
reveal it to Moses,
and this happens in the time of
the Exodus.
So in Exodus 6:2-3,
which is assigned by source
critics to the P source,
the Priestly source,
God appears to Moses and he
tells Moses then that he is
Yahweh.
He says, "I appeared to
Abraham, Isaac and Jacob," the
patriarchs before you,
"as El Shaddai,
but I did not make myself known
to them by name,
Yahweh."
So the P source has a different
sort of theology,
if you will,
of God's name,
or the revelation of God's
name.
And the same sort of thing
happens in Exodus 3:13-16,
and that's assigned to the E
source.
So once you've identified rough
blocks of material according to
not just the name of the deity
but also their assumptions about
when humankind knows the name of
the deity,
then you can analyze these
blocks or chunks of text and
begin to identify certain
characteristic features:
their style,
the terminology they use.
Source critics were able to
come up with a list of what they
believed were the main
characteristics of the various
sources.
So the main characteristics of
the J source,
which begins with the second
creation story,
so the J source picks up in
Genesis 2:4, second half of
verse 4 are: (1) that it uses a
personal name Yahweh for God
from the time of creation,
and that will be in your Bibles
as "Lord";
(2) It describes God very
anthropomorphically.
It's the J source that has God
shut the door of the ark after
Noah.
It's the J source that has God
smelling the sacrifice after the
Flood, the sacrifice that Noah
offers.
It's in the J source that God
eats with Abraham and bargains
with him.
It's in the J source that God
meets with Moses in this
mysterious passage and tries to
kill him one night;
(3) J has a very vivid and
concrete earthy style;
and, (4) It uses the name Mount
Sinai to refer to the place
where the Israelites with Moses
will conclude the covenant with
God.
As for the date?
Well source critics felt that a
clue to the dating of the J
source could be found in the
passage in which God promises a
grant of national land to the
Israelites.
The boundaries of the land are
given there as the River of
Egypt, the Nile,
and the Euphrates.
It was argued by some that
those were basically the borders
of the Kingdom of Israel under
David and Solomon.
Think of 1000 as your date for
David, that's basically when the
monarchy begins.
So the beginning of the tenth
century.
The argument is that under
David and Solomon the empire
reached that boundary and so
clearly this is a writer from
the tenth century who's seeking
to justify Israel's possession
of its kingdom from the River of
Egypt to the Euphrates;
it's presenting that kingdom as
a fulfillment of a promise of
land that God made to Israel's
ancient ancestors.
For that reason source critics
thought J must date to about the
tenth century and to the time of
perhaps King Solomon.
It also seems to reflect the
interests of the south.
Remember, we talked about the
fact briefly that at a certain
point in Israel's history there
is a division upon the death of
Solomon in the late tenth
century.
The kingdom divides into a
northern kingdom now called
Israel and a southern smaller
kingdom called Judah.
And the southern interests seem
to be reflected in the J
document.
So source critics decided this
is a Judean document from the
tenth century.
The E source,
which source critics say begins
around Genesis 15 is really the
most fragmentary.
It seems to have been used to
supplement the J source rather
than being used in a larger
form.
So sometimes it seems very
difficult to isolate,
and there's a lot of debate
over this,
but the E source's
characteristics are that (1) it
uses Elohim, again it's a plural
form of the word god or gods,
but when it's used with a
singular verb it refers to the
God of Israel;
(2) it has a much less
anthropomorphic view of God;
(3) God is more remote.
There aren't the direct
face-to-face revelations in the
E source;
most communications from the
divine are indirect.
They'll be through messengers
or dreams and;
(4) there's also an emphasis on
prophets and prophecy in the E
source.
Miriam, Moses--they're both
referred to as prophets in the E
source;
(5) The style is more abstract,
a little less picturesque,
and;
(6) the E source uses a
different name for the mountain
where the covenant was
concluded.
It uses the name Horeb.
So you will sometimes see as
you are reading the text,
they will sometimes refer to
Horeb instead of Mount Sinai,
or you'll see the two names
used interchangeably.
And it's been the theory of
scholars that that's because it
comes from a different source.
The E source seems to be
concerned primarily with the
northern tribes,
therefore the northern kingdom.
And so source theorists decided
that it was most likely composed
in the northern kingdoms about
the ninth century.
And then, according to this
hypothesis, the J and E sources
were combined,
primarily J with E being used
to supplement it,
probably somewhere in the eight
century, late eighth century;
and that was the backbone of
the Pentateuchal narrative.
It covers the early history of
humankind, of Israel's early
ancestors known as the
patriarchs and matriarchs.
Their stories are told in
Genesis.
It contained the story of Moses
and the exodus from Egypt in the
book of Exodus,
and the stories of the
wandering in the wilderness that
are found in the book of
Numbers.
The anonymous scribe or editor
who combined these sources
didn't care to remove any
redundant material or
contradictory material,
as we've already seen.
Now there are two other sources
according to classical source
theory, and these are D and P.
D, which is the Deuteronomic
source, is essentially the book
of Deuteronomy.
The book of Deuteronomy differs
from the narrative sources.
This is a book of speeches.
The book purports to be three
speeches delivered by Moses as
the Israelites are poised on the
east side of the Jordan River…
I'm not good with directions;
I had to stop and think… the
east side of the Jordan River,
about to enter the Promised
Land.
But according to the source
theorists it clearly reflects
the interests of settled
agrarian life.
It doesn't reflect the
interests of people who have
been wandering around
nomadically.
It has laws that deal with
settled agrarian life.
The main characteristic of D,
however, which assisted source
theorists in fixing its date,
is the following:
D is the one source in the
Bible that clearly insists that
one central sanctuary only is
acceptable to Yahweh.
God cannot be worshiped at
makeshift altars.
God cannot be worshipped
through sacrifices at some local
sanctuary;
all sacrifices must be offered
in the one central sanctuary
where "he will cause his name to
dwell."
It doesn't actually ever say
Jerusalem, which is why
Samaritans think that it's at
Mount Gerizim and that they have
the correct temple and that
they're authorized to offer
sacrifices.
They got it wrong when they
thought it was Jerusalem;
Samaritans think that that is
where God caused his name to
dwell.
So Jerusalem is not actually
mentioned in Deuteronomy,
that's a later reading,
but the place where God will
cause his name to dwell,
and only at the temple there,
can there be sacrifices.
This is a very different
perspective from other biblical
books.
So you're going to see in the
stories of the patriarchs that
they're wandering all around the
land and they're offering
sacrifices.
There are other books too where
it's clear that there are local
shrines, local sanctuaries,
local priests who are offering
sacrifices for people throughout
the land.
But Deuteronomy insists:
one central sanctuary.
All of the outlying alters and
sacred places must be destroyed.
Now centralization of the cult
was a key part of the religious
reform of a king of Judah in
622.
I've marked a couple of dates
on the timeline up here:
722 is the fall of the Northern
Kingdom, 622 a reform by King
Josiah in Judah .
We read about this in one of
the historical narratives where
the temple's being refurbished.
A book is found that says one
central sanctuary.
King Josiah says:
What have we been doing?
Get rid of the outlying altars,
everything has to be
centralized here.
So that reform,
Josiah's reform has caused many
scholars to associate
Deuteronomy,
the centralizing book or
source, with the late-seventh
century, around this time in
Judah.
The trouble is D seems to
reflect a lot of northern
traditions, the interests of
tribes who are in the north.
Well the Northern Kingdom was
destroyed in 722;
so this is the theory:
source critics conclude that D
is an old source that was
originally composed in the north
in the eighth century.
When the northern kingdom fell,
when the Assyrians conquered
and many Israelites would have
fled to the southern kingdom,
Deuteronomy or the D source was
brought to Jerusalem,
stored in the temple where a
hundred years later it was
discovered and its
centralization was put into
force by King Josiah.
P is the Priestly source,
and that is found mostly in the
books of Leviticus and the
non-narrative portions of
Numbers.
Now the major characteristics
of P, the Priestly source,
are (1) a great concern with
religious institutions,
with the sacrificial system,
with the Sabbath,
with holidays,
with rituals like circumcision,
the Passover,
dietary restrictions (the laws
of kashrut) the system of
ritual purity and impurity,
and also holiness,
ethical holiness and cultic or
ritual holiness.
P does have some narrative,
and you've read some of it:
Genesis 1, the first creation
account, is attributed to P.
It's orderly,
it's systematized,
the god is extraordinarily
abstract.
Because in the P source another
characteristic is that;
(2) God is transcendent,
and even perhaps remote,
much more so than in J,
for example.
Generally in the P source,
God is concealed and revealed
only in his kavod.
This is a word that's often
translated as "glory," but what
it refers to actually is a
light-filled cloud.
God seems to be the burning
fire inside this light-filled
cloud.
He travels before the
Israelites in that form,
leading them through the
wilderness and so on.
That seems to be in the P
source.
P is also; (3) interested in
covenants, in censuses,
in genealogies.
All of those sections very
often that link stories,
are attributed to the P source.
And because P elements often
serve that kind of function as a
bridge between stories,
or very often P sources seem to
introduce a story or conclude a
story, the source critics felt
that priestly writers were
probably responsible for the
final editing of the Bible,
bringing together J and E and D
and adding their materials and
finally editing the work.
Now, Wellhausen dated the
priestly source to the exilic
period, the period after the
fall of the Southern Kingdom in
586 when the Babylonians have
taken many of the Judeans into
exile in Babylon.
So the narrative parts of P,
J and E are continuous parallel
accounts of the history of the
world,
if you will,
from creation until the death
of Moses.
Source critics believe that
they have a uniform style,
uniform vocabulary,
uniform set of themes,
and chronological framework.
So according to Wellhausen,
and I sort of schematized it
chronologically for you up here,
the priestly school drew
together all of this older
material, added some of its own
editorial material--bridges,
introductions,
conclusions--inserted the large
priestly documents of Leviticus
and Numbers,
and so the Torah--and they did
this sitting in exile in
Babylon--and so the Torah is
really the result of five
centuries of religious and
literary activity.
And this of course is a very,
very different portrait from
traditional claims about the
authorship of the Pentateuch by
one man,
Moses, in approximately the
fourteenth century BCE.
There are different terms that
we use to describe the modern,
critical study of the Bible in
the late nineteenth century as
I've just described it.
One term is literary criticism,
because it proceeds by closely
analyzing the literary features
of the text: the terminology,
the style, the motifs.
But because the goal of this
literary critical school was to
identify specific sources,
isolate sources,
we also refer to it as source
criticism.
You'll see those terms used
interchangeably in your
literature.
Today literary criticism has a
slightly different connotation
from what it was in the
nineteenth century,
so people prefer the term
source criticism.
But you should know both are
used.
However, the purpose of
identifying and isolating these
sources was not just to say,
"Look at that,
there are these different
sources."
The purpose was to ascertain as
far as possible their relative
dates to one another,
and to therefore enable the
work of historical
reconstruction to proceed:
primarily a reconstruction of
the history of the religion of
Israel,
and the historical situation of
the authors of the different
sources.
Therefore literary criticism is
not only called source
criticism.
It's also called historical
criticism, because its ultimate
goal and purpose was not just to
isolate the sources,
but to arrange them according
to relative dates as far as they
might be ascertained,
and then to chart changes in
Israel's religion.
You have a very readable
introduction to some of this in
Norman Habel's little work.
Another excellent work which is
not on your syllabus that is
also critical of Wellhausen and
some of the biases in his work,
is found in a little work
called Who Wrote the
Bible by Richard Friedman,
which has a great cover because
it says "Who Wrote the
Bible? Richard Friedman,"
[audience laughter].
So to sum up:
the documentary hypothesis is
an effort to explain the
contradictions,
the doublets,
anachronisms and so on in the
Bible by means of hypothetical
source documents.
So the theory posits
hypothetical sources,
traditions and documents to
explain the current shape of the
Torah the way we have it,
to account for some of these
phenomena that we find.
As a next step the sources are
assigned relative dates,
not absolute dates,
relative dates,
and then they're analyzed to
reveal the different stages of
Israel's religious history.
And so source criticism is also
known as historical criticism
because it's a tool for getting
at the history,
not just at the text,
but ultimately a history of
Israelite religion.
That is how it has been used.
Now Wellhausen's work is subtle
and it's quite brilliant,
but it certainly reflects
biases of nineteenth- century
German scholarship,
which believed strongly in the
superiority of Christianity over
Judaism.
In his writings Wellhausen has
some things to say about Judaism
that are none too flattering.
He describes Judaism at the end
of the biblical period as a dead
tree, twisted and perverted.
He especially harbored a
distaste for things cultic:
priests, cult,
ritual, in keeping with what
was going on in Germany at the
time,
and the Protestant movement and
so on.
And these sorts of biases are
very apparent in his work,
and very apparent in his dating
of the sources,
and in his description of the
evolutionary stages of Israel's
religion.
So for example,
source critics before
Wellhausen all thought that P,
the priestly material,
was some of the oldest material
in the Bible,
that it was an early source.
But Wellhausen said no,
it must be a late source,
because priestly,
cultic, ritual material--that's
clearly a degenerate stage of
religion that shows a sort of
guilt-ridden behaviorism.
It's not true of spiritual
religion, so clearly that's the
latest stage of Israelite
religion when it had died and
was waiting to be reborn in new
form with the arrival of someone
in the first century.
Clearly his dating of P owes a
great deal to his biases and
religious ideology.
He saw the priestly material as
having to come from the -exilic
age, post 586,
and this is one of Wellhausen's
most controversial points that's
still hotly debated today,
and we're going to return to
this debate when we actually
take a look at Leviticus and
Numbers.
At that time we'll be able to
see what's at stake in the whole
question of the dating of the
priestly material.
The historical critical method,
and the documentary hypothesis
in particular,
are not inherently biased,
I want to make that point very
strongly.
They are simply analytical
tools: look at the text and its
features and draw some
conclusions based on what you're
finding.
They are simply analytical
tools.
They're not inherently biased.
They can be applied fairly to
the text, and they're
extraordinarily useful.
It's just that some of the
earlier practitioners of these
methods did have ideological
axes to grind,
and we need to be aware of
that.
The documentary hypothesis
works fairly well when you have
parallel accounts.
It works a little bit less well
when the accounts are interwoven
because sometimes picking apart
the sources can become dry and
mechanical,
sometimes to the point of
absurdity.
Some of the people who have
carried this method to its
extreme will go through and
almost word for word--this is J,
this is E, the next word is
P… it's quite remarkable how
certain they feel that they can
break things down almost on a
word-to-word basis as if an
editor sat there with scissors
and paste,
cutting out word for word,
and putting them together.
It sometimes can reach heights
of absurdity,
and it can really destroy the
power of a magnificent story,
sometimes, when you carve it up
into pieces that on their own
don't really make all that much
sense.
It needs to be remembered that
the documentary hypothesis is
only a hypothesis.
An important and a useful one,
and I certainly have used it
myself.
But none of the sources posited
by critical scholars has been
found independently:
we have no copy of J,
we have no copy of E,
we have no copy of P by itself
or D by itself.
So these reconstructions are
based on guesses.
Some of them are excellent,
excellent guesses,
very well supported by
evidence, but some of them are
not.
Some of the criteria invoked
for separating the sources are
truly arbitrary,
and extraordinarily subjective.
They are sometimes based on all
sorts of unfounded assumption
about the way texts were
composed in antiquity,
and the more that we learn
about how texts in antiquity
were composed,
we realize that it's perhaps
not unusual for a text to use
two different terms for the same
thing within one story,
since we find texts in the
sixteenth, seventeenth century
BCE on one tablet using two
different terms to connote the
same thing.
So the criteria that are
invoked for separating sources
often ignore the literary
conventions of antiquity,
and the more that we learn
about that the better able we
are to understand the way the
biblical text was composed.
Repetition isn't always a sign
of dual sources;
it often servers a rhetorical
function.
Variant terms aren't always a
sign of dual sources;
they may have a literary or
aesthetic function.
So most biblical scholars today
do accept some version of
Wellhausen's theory--yes,
we feel the Bible is composed
of different sources.
We don't always have tremendous
confidence, though,
in some of the finer details
and conclusions of his work and
the work of other scholars who
followed after him.
Some doubt the existence of E
altogether--it is so fragmentary
and so isolated.
Others defend the antiquity of
P --we'll be coming back to
that.
Others argue that everything is
post-exilic, everything's after
the fifth century.
It was written in the fourth,
third century in the Persian
period.
None of it comes from an older
Scandinavian scholars,
they're not enthusiastic about
source criticism at all.
The whole Copenhagen School of
Bible scholarship prefers--many
of them prefer--to see the Bible
as basically an oral narrative
that just grew through accretion
over time.
So I did assign readings in the
documentary hypothesis--it's
extraordinarily important--but
you do need to understand that
it is one hypothesis,
a major and controlling
hypothesis out there,
but it's not without criticism.
Moreover, while it's a very
important and worthwhile project
to analyze the component sources
and examine their specific
concerns and contribution,
and you'll see that I'm a very
great fan of P,
we must remember that whatever
sources were woven together,
they were woven together with
great skill and care by a final
redactor, or redactors,
who wanted them to be read as a
unity, and surely that must mean
something.
It must mean they can be
read as a unity and that that's
a challenge that's been issued
to us.
So the Bible can be read both
analytically and synthetically.
We need to combine an awareness
of origins, not gloss over the
problems and the contradictions
and say,
"Well, we can resolve it by
coming up with some strange
scenario that makes both things
work."
Be aware that there are
problems, contradictions,
these derive from different
sources, but also be sensitive
to the artistry of the final
composition.
What does it mean that both of
these elements have been
retained here side by side?
What is the phrase?
The whole is greater than the
sum of the parts.
So keep that awareness.
And in the last 20 years or so,
source criticism--actually 30
years or so--source criticism in
the conventional sense of the
analysis of documentary sources
has been supplemented by other
new and exciting methodologies
in the study of the Bible,
and we'll see some of those.
I've also included as optional
reading for you sometimes,
a couple of articles that
analyze biblical stories.
They are written by someone who
thinks that documentary
hypothesis just doesn't really
help us out much at all,
and she gives some wonderful,
coherent readings of stories
that argue this scene here or
this contradiction here isn't a
sign of a different source;
it serves this literary
purpose, that literary purpose.
And I put those in subversively
for you to have a look at in
your own time.
They're brilliantly written and
they give you insight into the
various ways in which we can
read the text.
But many of the alternative
methodologies for studying the
text do assume sources,
in some broad sense even if not
all the details of Wellhausen's
theory, so it's clear that a
great deal of biblical
scholarship owes its
accomplishments and its theories
to the work that was done by the
source critics of the nineteenth
century.
I want to flip back to text for
a moment before I return to talk
about a whole contradictory set
of methodologies,
or methodologies that pull in
another direction.
But first I want to get us up
to the patriarchs and matriarchs
where we're going to be starting
off on Monday.
We have just had a flood,
and then we move into Genesis
10;
and Genesis 10 contains a
genealogical table of nations.
In this table,
peoples of various lands are
portrayed as having descended
from a common source,
a common ancestor,
Noah, through his three sons,
Japheth, Ham and Shem.
Shem: Shemites, Semites.
Shemites are said to descend
from Noah's son,
Shem.
The biblical text at this point
is understanding humanity as
basically sharing a common root
united by a common language.
The story that follows in
Genesis 11 can be understood
then as an etiological tale,
a tale that comes to explain
something, and this tale is
coming to explain the
diversification of language:
when we look around we see that
in fact people don't seem to be
that united and are in fact
divided by their languages and
so on.
So how are we to account for
the diversification of
languages, the spread of
different ethnic linguistic
groups throughout the lands of
the earth if we all come from
one common creative moment,
one common ancestor?
Genesis 11 explains that.
The story is therefore going to
act as a bridge between the
first section of Genesis which
has a universal scale,
a universal scope,
and what happens in Genesis
beginning in Chapter 12,
where we're going to focus in
on one ethnic,
linguistic group and one land.
This story serves as the
bridge, first of all explaining
how it is that a united humanity
speaking a common language even
becomes diversified
linguistically and ethnically,
to then focus in on one group
and one land.
Babel, pronounced
"bavel" in Hebrew,
is Babylon.
The tower in the story of the
Tower of Babel is identified by
scholars as a very famous tower,
a ziggurat, a ziggurat to
Marduk in Babylon.
The Bible's hostility to
Babylon--after all it's going to
be the Babylonians who are going
to destroy them in 586--but the
Bible's hostility to Babylon and
its imperialism is clear.
This story has a satirical tone.
The word Babel,
Bavel,
means Gate of the God,
but it's the basis for a
wonderful pun in Hebrew,
which also actually happens to
work in English.
Babble nonsensical speaking,
confusion of language.
And I think there's obviously
some onomatopoeic quality to
"Babel" that makes it have that
kind of a meaning both in
English and a similar word in
Hebrew.
So this word can also with a
little bit of punning mean
confusion, or confused language.
So this mighty tower that was
obviously the pride of Babylon
in the ancient world is
represented by the biblical
storywriter as the occasion for
the confusion of human language.
The construction of Marduk's
ziggurat is represented as
displeasing to God.
Why?
There are very many possible
interpretations and our
commentaries are full of them.
Some interpreters view the
tower builders as seeking to
elevate themselves to storm
heaven by building a tower with
its top in the sky.
Others see the builders as
defying God's direct order.
Remember, God said,
"Be fruitful and multiply and
fill the earth," spread out and
fill the earth.
But these people are said to
come together,
they congregate in one place,
and instead of spreading out
they're trying to rise high.
There seems to be a real
defiance of God's design for
humanity, and so God frustrates
their plan for
self-monumentalizing,
and he scatters them over the
face of the earth.
He makes it more difficult for
them to do this again by
confusing their tongues.
Once again there's a very steep
learning curve for this God.
He has to keep adjusting things
depending on what it is that
humans are doing.
So now he's got to confuse
their languages.
Some interpreters see this
story as representing a
rejection of civilization or
certain aspects of civilization.
Monumental architecture,
empire building,
these are always things that
are looked upon with suspicion
for most of the biblical sources
and biblical writers.
Those sorts of ambitions are
viewed negatively.
They lead to human
self-aggrandizement.
They are indicative of an
arrogant sort of
self-reliance--that the prophets
will certainly rail against--and
in some sense a forgetting of
God.
So this is a time in which
humans spread out,
lose their unity,
and this is also a time really
when they turn to the worship of
other gods.
The first 11 chapters of
Genesis then have given us a
cosmic, universal setting for
the history of Israel.
Those first chapters cover 2500
years if you go through and add
up the chronologies.
The rest of Genesis,
Genesis 12 through 50,
will cover just four
generations: the generations of
the patriarchs and the
matriarchs.
They will be Abraham and Sarah;
their son Isaac,
his wife Rebekah;
their son Jacob,
his two wives Rachel and Leah,
I am leaving out other wives;
but finally their children,
12 sons and one daughter.
So God's focus has shifted
dramatically,
the text's focus has shifted
dramatically.
Why?
When you get to the end of
Genesis 11 you feel that God has
been rather shut out.
Things aren't going well.
Although God created the earth
as an intrinsically good
paradise, he created humans in
his image,
he provided for them,
humans to this point have put
their moral freedom pretty much
to poor use.
Many scholars,
Kaufman, Sarna and others,
say that one of the differences
then between these myths of
Israel and the mythologies of
their neighbors is that in
Ancient Near Eastern mythologies
you have the struggle of good
and evil cosmic powers.
In the myths of the Bible this
is replaced by a struggle
between the will of God and
rebellious humans.
So these myths are telling also
of a struggle,
but it's on a different plane.
Adam and Eve,
Cain, the generation of the
flood, the builders of the tower
of Babel--God has been
continually spurned or thwarted
by these characters.
So he's withdrawing his focus,
and is going to choose to
reveal himself to one small
group,
as if to say,
"Okay, I can't reach everybody,
let me see if I can just find
one person,
one party, and start from there
and build out."
And so in Genesis 12 which
begins the second stage of the
Bible's historical narrative,
we read that God calls to Abram
to leave the land of his fathers
and travel to a land which God
will show him,
beginning a whole new stage of
the biblical narrative,
and we'll sense that there's a
very different feeling when you
get to Genesis 12.
When you read that material,
it will feel different to you.
And because of that we need to
talk a little bit more about
ways to read the biblical text,
methods of criticism and so on.
In preparation for looking at
the biblical narrative material
that deals specifically with the
Israelites,
we need to think of some,
or learn about some,
of the other critical
methodologies that are used in
biblical scholarship,
and for a moment we're going to
the adopt the role of historian.
I'm going to ask you to think
like historians--whatever that
might mean--now and as we move
into next week and look at
Genesis 12 through 50.
The source critical method that
we talked about today focuses on
the hypothetical period of the
compilation of the text,
the compilation of the four
sources into the Torah.
But later scholars began to
ask, "Well, what about the
pre-history of those sources?
What were the sources' sources?"
Why should that be important?
Remember that the source
critics claimed and concluded
that J, E, P and D were written
from the tenth to the sixth
centuries,
and the implication,
well actually not just the
implication, the strong
assertion of many of them was
that despite the fact that they
purport to tell of events prior
to 1000,
in fact they're just not at all
reliable for those periods.
They were written centuries
after the fact,
we really can't know anything
about Israel,
Israel's religion,
Israel's history,
religious history before the
tenth century.
That was a very dissatisfying
conclusion to many people,
because the writers of J,
E, P and D probably didn't sit
down at typewriters and just
invent their documents out of
whole cloth.
It doesn't seem that that's the
way these materials would have
been composed.
They didn't invent,
probably, all of these cultic
rules and ritual practices all
of a sudden.
It seems likely that they were
drawing on older traditions
themselves: older stories,
older customs,
older laws, ritual practices.
Scholars in the next wave of
biblical scholarship began to
ask a different set of
questions;
they became interested in
asking: what materials did the
compiler or the compilers of J
or E or P draw on in the
composition of those sources?
Did they use more ancient
materials, and if so can we
figure out what they were?
Do they contain reliable
traditions for an earlier stage?
And if so, then maybe we do
have access after all to
information regarding Israelite
history prior to the year 1000.
Suddenly you see an analytical
approach to the Bible that's
going to pull in the exact
opposite direction from the
classical source theory.
One of the leading scholars to
take up this question was
Hermann Gunkel,
whose name is at the top over
there.
Gunkel had a great knowledge of
the oral literature of other
cultures, other nations,
and that led him to ask:
Can we perhaps analyze these
four literary source documents
and figure out the pre-literary
stages of their development?
What went into their
compilation and composition?
He found support for this idea
within the Bible itself because
at times the Bible seems to name
earlier sources quite
explicitly.
We don't have records of those
sources anymore,
but they seem to be named in
the Bible.
In Numbers 21:14 there's a
little poetic excerpt that gives
the boundaries between Moab and
the Amorites,
and it's quoted and it says
it's from the Book of the Wars
of the Lord.
It's quoted as if this is a
source that the person is
drawing on and using in the
composition of his text,
and it's quoted in a way that
makes it sound as if the source
should be familiar to the
reader.
We also have mention of
something called the Book of
Yashar in Joshua,
that's also quoted,
in Joshua 10:13.
Or in 2 Samuel 1:18,
we have David lamenting,
a very beautiful lament over
the death of Saul and his
beloved Jonathan.
It seems to actually be an epic
song that recounts acts of
Israel's heroes.
He's reciting that now as he
laments over the death of these
two, and so it seems to be an
earlier source that's been put
into the story of David and his
lament.
So it seems reasonable in light
of the practices of other
people, other ancient cultures
and literatures as well as some
contemporary literatures,
and it seems reasonable in
light of the explicit citation
of sources in the biblical text
to suppose that in fact the four
primary documents are themselves
compilations from other source
materials,
or drawing on written or oral
materials from an even earlier
period.
Gunkel began to focus on small
little units.
He was interested in small
units within the four primary
documents, and he identified
genres or forms,
what he called forms.
The German word is a
Gattung,
Gattungen,
forms.
He would identify these small
units, and that gave rise to the
name of this approach,
which is form criticism.
He believed that what he was
doing was identifying older,
pre-literary forms that had
been taken up and incorporated
by the literary sources,
by J, E, P and D.
Examples of the kind of form,
or Gattung,
that he would identify are
things like a hymn,
a proverb--we often have
biblical texts quoting proverbs
that seem to be folk
sayings--laws,
rituals, folk stories of a
particular type,
poems, legends,
songs, fragments of mythology.
So for example he says of
Genesis 6:1-4,
a passage that you've read:
When men began to
increase on earth and daughters
were born to them,
the divine beings saw how
beautiful the daughters of men
were and took wives from among
those that pleased them.
The Lord said,
"My breath shall not abide in
man forever, since he too is
flesh;
let the days allowed him be one
hundred and twenty years."
It was then,
and later too,
that the Nephilim [these giants
of some kind]
appeared on earth--when the
divine beings cohabited with the
daughters of men,
who bore them offspring [these
giants, these Nephilim].
They were the heroes of old,
the men of renown.
That's just stuck in there,
in Genesis 6:1-4.
This is an older fragment of a
mythology or a legend which is
put into place here.
It's explaining the origin of
heroes and great men of renown
in the old days.
He also says that there are
etiological stories.
We've talked about
those--legends that give the
origin of a name,
or a ritual,
or an institution.
There are different types of
etiological stories.
He says there are ethnological
legends that will give you the
story accounting for the origin
of a particular people:
so the Moabites for example,
and the Ammonites--not a
flattering story at all
following the destruction of
Sodom and Gomorrah.
Obviously the Israelites didn't
care for those people very much
and gave them a pretty nasty
origin.
We also have etymological
legends, because they're
explaining the name of
something.
It's given this particular name
because of an etymomological
connection with some event
earlier.
So all of these things,
he argues, are probably older
existing traditions that have
been taken up and adapted by the
biblical writer,
and they may preserve some
historical reminiscence.
More importantly,
more important then the actual
events that they might be
reporting, is the fact that
behind each of these is some
sort of function.
Each one of these did some sort
of cultural work,
it had some function or setting
in life.
That's what we can discover
when we isolate these forms:
this setting in life.
That helps us learn something
about ancient Israelite society
or culture way before the tenth
century.
That's Gunkel's claim.
So form criticism wasn't
content with just identifying
these various types of material,
these various genres;
it asked what was their
function?
What was their Sitz im
Leben?
What was their situation in
life, their cultural context?
What does it tell us that we
have a large number of
liturgical texts?
What does it tell us that we
have a large number of texts
that seem to point to some sort
of judicial context?
What does it tell us that we
have a great deal of proverbs,
or wisdom material in certain
parts of the Bible that we might
date to a certain time?
What does this tell us about
society and what people were
doing?
Growing out of form criticism
is tradition criticism.
This is a type of criticism
that focuses on the transmission
of traditional material through
various stages,
oral stages and literary
stages, until it reaches its
present form in the text.
Now you can imagine as a story
is told and then it's retold,
it is obviously changed and
adapted.
Tradition criticism looks at
that.
Looking at Ancient Near Eastern
parallels is very helpful.
You can see how some of those
motifs and themes were changed
in the process of being
transmitted within Israelite
culture and society,
and again, to serve some sort
of cultural function,
or purpose.
So the present text of the
Pentateuch obviously rests on a
very, very long period of
transmission,
both oral recitation and
very much like the Greek
classics, Homer's classics,
the Odyssey,
the Iliad:
they also had a long history of
oral recitation and
transmission,
and were transformed along the
way.
Tradition criticism likes to
look at the way people receive
traditional material,
rework it in creative ways and
then adapt it to their own
purposes and contexts and
transmit it.
Sometimes that process is
reflected in the Bible itself.
Traditions in one part of the
Bible will be picked up in a
later part of the Bible,
and written rather differently
with a different point of view.
So Deuteronomy,
for example,
recounts events that we've also
read about in Exodus,
and sometimes the differences
are startling.
Sometimes there are completely
new emphases and the story can
come out to be a very,
very different story.
1 and 2 Chronicles are a
retelling and a reworking of
much of the material from
Genesis through 2 Kings,
and it cleans up a lot of the
embarrassing moments.
It presses its own themes in
retelling those stories.
Early laws are subject to
reinterpretation.
Ezekiel comes along and does
some interesting things with
some of the legal material that
we find in Leviticus.
This is all the kind of thing
that tradition criticism looks
at.
Tradition criticism wants to
uncover the changes that occur
in the transmission of
traditional material.
It's already happening--we can
see it--within the Bible,
and the assumption therefore is
that it happens before the
material even gets into the
Bible.
Perhaps we can figure some of
that out, and it's a process
that also aids in historical
reconstruction.
So you can see after classic
source criticism,
which came along and leveled
people's interest in anything
before the tenth century,
and said: all we have are these
written accounts that reflect
the biases of the people at the
time who wrote them,
you then have the rise of types
of scholarship that say:
we're not satisfied with that.
That's not really how
literature works.
People don't sit down and
invent things out of whole
cloth, particularly material of
this type.
It clearly has a history,
they're clearly drawing on
sources and maybe we can use
analytical tools to figure out
something about the period that
you might think would be lost to
history.
So these types of criticism are
emphasizing the real life
historical setting of the
materials that are in the
biblical sources,
their relationship to the wider
culture, and that's something
that earlier source criticism
didn't care too much about.
All of these analytical modes
of studying the Bible--by
analytical I mean sitting down
and analyzing the features,
the literary features of the
text, and drawing conclusions
from them--all of these modes of
examining the Bible--most of
them developed by German
scholars--can be contrasted with
the North American tradition of
scholarship which emphasized the
correlation of biblical and
archaeological data.
I've written the name Albright;
William F.
Albright, was a leading scholar
at the American school of
biblical studies,
and he was an expert in the
fields of Palestinian
archaeology and Assyriology.
He focused on illustrating the
Bible with the Ancient Near
Eastern sources that at that
time were newly coming to
light-- archaeological findings;
and his argument was--and it's
an argument that's to a large
degree not accepted anymore
but--his argument at the time
was that archaeology supported
the basic historicity of
biblical tradition.
There are some definite
problems, however,
with viewing the Bible as
history.
There are certainly problems
with chronology:
it's hard to pin down dates for
a lot of things.
Many of the events are given
more then one date.
A lot of the numbers...the
Bible tends to use ideal
numbers;
it tends to use fives and
multiples of five,
or multiples of five plus
seven.
You have ten generations from
Adam to Noah.
Noah to Abram.
These things begin to raise
suspicions.
We have suspicious repetitions
of events, things that happened
to two or more of the
patriarchs: twice Abraham goes
into foreign territory and tries
to pass his wife off as his
sister.
Isaac does the same thing.
Are these three versions of one
basic tradition that got
assigned to different
patriarchs?
Are we supposed to think of
these as representing three
separate historical incidents?
What's the likelihood of these
things happening?
Is that historically reasonable?
So there are lots of reasons to
feel that biblical chronologies
of the patriarchal period are
not accurate historical records:
I use that phrase with some
timidity.
But in the twentieth century
scholars of Albright's school
argued that many of the
traditions in the book of
Genesis contained authentic
reflections of the historical
period they claimed to deal
with.
And they cited a number of
considerations.
We'll take those up on Monday,
but I would like you--as you
read Genesis 12 and forward and
think about that material--I'd
like you to ask yourself:
Is this historical writing?
By what criteria do I judge
historical writing?
What do I think historical
writing is?
What makes some writing
historical?
What makes other writing
fictional?
Where do we get these genres
from?
Why is so important to us to
figure out what this is?
Think about some of those
issues, and we'll talk a little
bit more about that as we turn
to the texts in Genesis 12.